c'est une galette dont on pensait perdre
la recette de la fin des années 80 mais
la voilà qui se met à dévorer les parts
de marché ça tombe bien pour david qui
ont fait son beurre hallyday des cow
boys
il trace son sillon parmi les grands
dans son atelier du au double il est
gravé traite jusqu'à cette matrice par
jour dont les deux tiers pour des
maisons de disques à l'étranger ces
trois dernières années c'est la folie
c'est vraiment même moi qui suis dans le
milieu je m'attendais pas à 100 vous
êtes débordés ouais ouais ouais je
travaille quasiment 7 jours sur 7
c'est assez difficile vous refuser des
commandes
oui oui je suis un peu près entre 60 et
80 % des demandes
un crève coeur et des marchés perdus
pour une toute jeune entreprise qui ne
demande qu'à grandir
né en 2012 que ting alvano forming
dégage des bénéfices depuis trois ans
mais une panne lui fait perdre 30 mille
euros l'an dernier
la solution racheter une machine pour
éviter que l'histoire ne se répète
mais la banque refuse de suivre faute de
fonds propres l'ancien dj on appelle
donc au financement participatif
si vous avez eu dix mille euros en
participatif vous espérer convaincre les
banques mais en fait si on arrive à
grossir notre apport de capital ça va
enclencher aussi une aide régionale qui
elle va déclencher la banque
dans l'idéal il faudrait
avoir une somme à peu près de cinquante
soixante mille euros pouvoir retaper la
machine installée a grandi des locaux la
cagnotte court jusqu'en septembre si
tout se passe sans fausse note david
pourra passer à la phase b de son plan
embauché une voire deux personnes parce
que le marché est vraiment porter parce
qu'ils ne sont que deux à l'alimenter
dans toute l'europe reste à galvaniser
les troupes pour mettre les banques au
diapason